welcome back wow it's been a while been
a couple of months even i i can't even
tell you i i already feel myself tearing
up i can't tell you how wonderful
it is to have you back
we missed you so much i missed you guys
big time and i should explain what i've
been doing and say first of all i'm just
grateful to be here i can honestly say
that i am a changed man because i went
through a battle with covet so at the
end of july i came down with what i
thought was a bad cold at first it got
progressively worse and i didn't worry
too much about it because i'd actually
received the first of two shots and i
actually and i thought i'd had it last
year so i might have had the antibodies
so it wasn't a big thing in my mind but
it just got worse and worse and as we
know by now covert affects everybody
differently i never lost my sense of
smell or taste but the virus mounted a
vicious attack on my respiratory system
one that landed me in the hospital for
nearly a week now not many people know
about this i've never posted anything on
social media that's the first time i've
talked about it publicly
but i do want to say publicly a thank
you to the nurses at summerlin hospital
they were amazing they worked so hard
and do so much with care and compassion
my brother flew up here from texas to
take care of me for a week i have an
incredible family
my kids took good care of me friends
brought me dinners i have a lot to be
thankful for for sure so i still have a
long recovery head as far as lung
capacity goes but i'm headed in the
right direction
i just want to say this i know that the
vaccine is for some people a divisive
topic and i understand why some people
are scared to get it i don't think the
shaming that's been done shaming people
who are vaccine hesitant is productive
so i'll say this the doctors told me the
vaccine likely saved my life
and it could have been a lot worse
so i just want to ask everybody to
research it really look into it i simply
don't want to see any of you any of my
friends or family go through what i did
and i say that fully understanding that
what i went through doesn't even compare
to many others who have had much worse
cases and certainly now the hundreds of
thousands who have lost their lives to
covet but it man i can't tell you how
happy i am to be sitting next to you and
be here kendall we love you so much and
we know that it was a difficult time for
you and just having you back here with
us you're part of this family and
i i just i can't stress to you how much
we are just happy that you're you're
healthy and we love you so much i love
you guys and i'm so so happy
okay now that i'm crying and everything
but can i just ask you how you're
feeling now how are you doing now
it's just a matter of getting these
lungs back in order i walk across the
studio and i'm breathing hard and they
said it's about a nine month recovery i
i did see um a good sign that you were
feeling back to normal because he was
telling his dad jokes uh earlier today
so i was like okay
he's getting there slowly but show me
and maybe we'll share this one if we
have time
all right well